déjà on vous a préparé un nouveau jeu
vous allez voir un jeu très simple qui
va se passer là chacun doit choisir une
carte dans un instant la plus petite
carte va jongler je vais vous dire de
quoi il en retourne là ça y est on
m'amène 1 voilà bah voilà voilà
et ben voilà je voulais que vous dire
c'est que celui qui va perdre va devoir
refaire toutes les poses de clara
morgane
on fera vraiment un vrai calendrier et
fera toutes les pauses pendant les pubs
vous verrez on vous montrera calendrier
à la fin pardon c'est rien si on peut
mettre ça vraiment dans ma loge un lien
bien deux côtés merci ah oui il ya même
un verseau c'est important merci merci
alors ça on verra ça dans l'instant vers
et tous les garçons ont joué pas défi
d'accord les filles sont exemple pour
les raisons évidentes
voilà merci voilà on a y compris un
polar non mais c'est vrai on rire voilà
merci je sais qu'on peut pas le faire
mais dans un arrêt dont chacun prendre
une carte
je vais jouer aussi il y en a un il n'y
en a qu'un qui est exempté et je vous
dirai de qu'il s'agit dans un instant et
pour quel motif
ces écarts de gérard louvin pour qu'il
va mieux merci allait bien et il allait
bien elle n'est pas allée pas là depuis
longtemps
on voit qu'elle a fait un stage d'humour
qui veut mélanger puisque après vous
allez me dire que je suis un tricheur
mind calaisis et donc à aidant à une
rhino son talent et il sait non plus et
son retour c'est bon non non mais
mélanger bitaoui très dit non alors
calmez vous calmez vous merci on va
prendre chacun une carte la plus petite
carte devra refaire le calendrier de
clara morgane le petit tous les gars
sont d'accord les chéris attention on y
va on va démarrer alors y'en a qui va
pas le faire c'est jean luc pascal joly
pourrait ce qui doit préparer ces
questions 4/3 pour le prime un joli cet
anniversaire les 302 débite ya des cas
tiers très très très très très
importante et est donc voilà donc elle
s'est construit d'abord par il travaille
pendant les pubs
furia opérations du tout pas du tout
quelle est votre carte bleue regarder
devant vous la petite carte
je rappelle que ça va de 2 ha à la plus
grande carte célas la publique arte
c'est le devine si on reste 30 secondes
et une âme et je suis à paul semaine
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon pour de l'homme en joker
police lévesque le valais c'est bon et
bien ce sera juste
[Applaudissements]
dans le calme vers le bas
alors qu'arras on a demandé à julien
courbet de refaire notre calendrier un
bien sûr avant de reprendre avec camille
combal les missions normales alors vous
avez donc refait le calendrier clara
morgane vous avez fait qu'elle mois il a
fait qu'elle mois il a fait pour tout
dire quand j'ai regardé la photo le
premier truc que je crois que ç'a eu les
c 'est pas julien courbet tout à fait
comme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas la mer quelque chose
d'excitant d'accord c'est là sur wii ça
là on aime bien ça j'ai pas fait ça
n'est pas fait
[Rires]
ah oui oui oui c'est là il a fait cela
je crois non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]